12 secondes c'est squeeze aujourd'hui se
trouve sur dark déception' des gars qui
a un gameplay qui ressemble à pac man
mais qui fait quand même bien peur oui
je sais possible ok donc là elle nous
explique des fragments spirituel qu'on
doit ramasser
il ya un monstre c'est quelque chose que
j'ai pris de dons pire cauchemar ah
ouais t'as réussi à me trouver milk est
nu c'est sa voix c'est parti on prend
les échardes voilà donc c'est pour ça
que c'est sûr de pac-man s'il faut
ramasser plein de trucs par terre comme
pacman on doit ramasser les housses et
bien sombre là bas c'est bon ça va
oh je sais que du noir j'ai peur du noir
mais m à chaque tournant j'ai peur quoi
c'est scandaleux ont été horribles avec
grosses têtes [ __ ] était de plus
grosse que moi plus grosse que ma tête
oui c'est vraiment pas de haine qui
faisaient alors [ __ ] puis ça prend
direct d'accord j'ai trois vies voyez si
c'est badge de policier en haut à gauche
schéma pourquoi mais en tout cas ces
bâches des policiers alors on ne se pose
pas de question et maintenant à droite
qui m'indique où sont à peu près les
fragments sujet là c'est que j'en prends
moi je vends trouvé logique imparable un
os apprendre à vous regarder après votre
beauté matière il est vrai il attendait
comme ça tranquillement si j'attends
comme ça tranquillement au les deux
états mais quand j'ai peur babouche et
transforme en poulpe c'est génial non
mais j'ai plus de vis est mort un an
mais là c'était la version testée tout
et l'hôtel me dit il arrive à merci il
est à deux mètres et peut-être qu'il
n'arrivait pas finalement qu'ils étaient
juste là en train de faire une séance
photo non bien sûr qu'il arrivait avec
ses couteaux j'ai quitté le jeu comme ça
même on est hantée brady il s'est mis
vers le bas maintenant que nous avons
compris le jeu et qui nous sommes très
très fort
c'est parti donc là trop mais non mais
dès le début ils arrivent fait une
petite surprise comme ça au coin au nom
au nom
prenons alors par là alors pourquoi
bonus + 10 10 éclats parce que je suis
nul c'est ça vous avez encore pitié de
moi foutu jeu vidéo elle est pas bien
mais pas bien du tout froid [ __ ] mais
c'est super l'agent fait parce que quand
tu cours
il arrive très vite sur toi voilà
attendait il nous reste que 130 échardes
avec de vie est il se passe un truc là
à droite et à gauche comme ça chez fleux
donner de la tête et des poils partout
de singe ça puait la moelle ya cinq ans
à brader attend surtout parce qu'ils
aiment bien mettre un angle comme ça ils
regardent avec leur tête poilus il faut
ou apprendre regarder
voyez quoi quand on parle du loup il est
là du singe dégueu il est ça met une
pression de dingue on va gagner on va
gagner on va gagner mais c'est un fait
inquiète apporte sa déconner le gvt et
aux à l'état de stress total en fait
c'est super et 3es et moi je paye tous
plus trop forte donc ça tombe bien là la
dernière la dernière la dernière comment
gères mais il en restait une elle était
là comme ça elle attendait au tournant
sur elle-même car je suis seul sans toi
j'arrive échardes en fait plus je
ramasse des éclats plus il y a deux
singes musiciens sur la mappe voilà si
on peut appeler ça des musiciens il faut
un peu penser aux persos de fatal
olive parce qu'en fait les des animaux
voilà ce bruyant témoigne tiendra du
contraire un du vin ne fait pas de bruit
sauf coach comme le petit doigt de pied
contre un baby est vrai ça c'est moi
tous les matins à dieu j'ai un début de
calvitie
un matin il restait une j'arrive pas à
me remettre c'est l'un des plus gros
traumatisme de ma vie c'est vous dire
c'est vous dire ce que j'ai vécu
regardez est ce que c'est une occupation
reste que c'est un passe temps ça non oh
oh tais toi
il arrive mais non je vois là c'est ça
c'est le problème quand tu regarde la
carte c'est comme ça mais l'été echave
là aussi je suis plutôt bien je suis je
suis bloqué voilà il me dérange en
pleine discussion avec une table basse
je n'accepterai plus jamais ça la
prochaine fois je change de jeu merde et
howie elle a dit si l'armée en rigolant
un peu psy elle est contente dans sa
barbe cette pauvre femme ce qu'elle a de
la barbe cette pauvre femme comprend la
droite prend l'avion je n'ai entendu il
a voulu me couper les cheveux vous avez
entendu il ya eu des bruits de géants de
même de jouer je peux voler un peu plus
cher de lui passer le balai papa en oui
on a trouvé on a trouvé nos restent
vains sans papa j'arrive ma douce
j'arrive mantoue clermont new moon ou
éclats il en reste une
j'arrive à 12 je suis là pour toi
oh non non elle doit en train de pleurer
tout soit l'état pictures espère ramener
j'ai fait une fausse manip
j'ai fait une fausse manip compte
évacuer la pression comme ça mais ça
c'est cette [ __ ] de boutons sur la
souris sur le côté pour faire précédent
suivant ce pauvre éclaire encore dans le
néant seul os ça m'attriste ce qui est
bien c'est que là on est passé de une
est chère à 246 fait qu'il ya un écart
considérable puisque je suis un peu prof
de maths aux olives in extremis
salamandre vrai que déjà qu'il ne me
coupe pas en 2x et les frissons 24 24
tais toi arrête de dire qu'il arrive
c'est pas vrai j'aurais dû écouter vous
tâchez désolé deux fois il ne restait
plus qu'une seule petite victoire
je sais très bien comme on ait fait ça
c'est que je fais toute confiance que je
dis aux mères mais elles seront timing
était parfait quoi c'est un singe
professionnels vraiment replay cette
fois c'est la bonne je ne veux pas tout
introduction femmes qui me disent à 6h30
et qui en fait tu rigoles dans sa dans
son duvet blond je vais écouter
uniquement fous toi qui regarde à jean
talon ce pardon pour déjà la couleur est
beaucoup trop fin pour qu'ils puissent
rentrer ça c'est la première chose ya pa
deuxième chose j'espère que la première
vous a plu thain reste 17e
mais qu'est ce que j'ai fait mais c'est
chez psa coca tire mon oeil le coin
comme ça au nom il aurait subi une non
on a réussi 0e je regarde la pièce du
puzzle sa quête mais qu'est ce qu'on
s'en fout n'a pas reçu non non non c'est
la selas et là c'est la base
entendez-vous cette foule en délire et
ses applaudissements assourdissant parce
que moi non bon eh voilà j'ai un staff
1,7 et 2 sur ce petit jeu indé d'arc
décéption c'est juste une démo et
s'annonce quand même très très cool
c'est vrai qu'on peut dire que c'est le
même mécanisme de batman mais avec des
singes qui font comme ça en plus et des
couloirs qui font la largeur de ton
corps à j'espère que ça vous a plu c'est
le cas n'hésitez pas vu la vidéo ça fait
vraiment plaisir je pense rejoint lé jeu
quand la version finale sortira là c'est
qu'une démo du démo d'une alfa d'une
démo en finale c'est comme ça j'ai par a
+ plus là c'est scandaleux
j'étais beaucoup mieux dans la manche de
mon switch à tout le monde pitts